I want to talk about some of the
parallels between the 2020 Democratic
primary and the 2016 Democratic primary
which are almost mirror images in a
sense except we had more candidates
splitting the vote this time around
until closer to the end of the primary
process and I hope that this is
instructive to us what are the sort of
recipe adjustments that we should be
looking at is an open question that we
have to think about but take a look at
this back in 2016 you had Hillary
Clinton in the lead as the presumptive
frontrunner basically from day one she's
the purple line on the chart that we're
looking at in comes Bernie Sanders and
slowly but surely he starts chipping
chipping away at her support the brown
line on the chart that were showing our
video audience and Bernie starts closing
in on Hillary Clinton and then it
becomes almost a tie and then the entire
thing reverses Hillary Clinton rebuilds
her lead sales into the nomination
despite months of well Bernie could
still catch up if he grabs this state
Bernie could still catch up if he grabs
that state or whatever that was 2016
let's now look at the 20/20 chart more
can that it's a much more colorful chart
but we have another very similar
situation Biden enters and immediately
spikes to 44% Bernie drops to below 15
but then the debates start the
campaign's get going and slowly but
surely Biden's green line of support
here starts to dissent it starts to
trickle off while Bernie's blue line
starts to climb and this time it
actually passed Biden compared to only
equating Hillary back in 2016
Bernie actually builds a national lead
and then in this case in the last six to
seven days essentially it reverses
Bernie drops Biden passes him and my
prediction is that this will become a
bigger and bigger lead for Joe Biden
nationally so why does this happen why
did it happen almost the exact same way
both times different candidates
different number of people running
different time line in terms of when it
happened it's very easy to say the DNC
establishment did it and we talked about
this a little bit earlier today
obviously the DNC establishment has a
big role to play why do you think the
day before Super Tuesday
aimée drops out and endorses Biden two
days before Pete drops out and endorses
Biden bateau or Roarke comes out of the
woodwork and endorses Biden obviously
the DNC establishment knows if all these
people stay in Bernie likely ends up
with a plurality although not a majority
if these people get out and support
Biden Biden likely ends up with the
delegate lead which he has now by more
than 60 delegates and in all likelihood
sails to the nomination that's all true
but if that's as far as our analysis
goes we are going to continue to see
moderates nominated and there is more to
it and we've been talking about it
Bernie was counting on younger voters
they were m.i.a
they were missing they didn't show up on
Tuesday Biden's older voters showed up
the progressive left always counts on
these young voters and they rarely show
up so is that a viable strategy I would
argue the answer is no as shown by the
evidence number two I already mentioned
it when you are enmeshed in online
culture that includes Twitter and reddit
and YouTube and as soon as you say hey
you know I'm a little tiny bit worried
about exactly how Medicare for all will
be implemented and you get shouted down
the way I've been many times despite
being a Bernie supporter and a supporter
of Medicare for all you start to become
disconnected from the reality on the
ground there are a ton of Democratic
primary voters who don't like Bernie
they're not interested in the total
package they'd support Medicare for all
under a number of circumstances they'd
support free college they believe Amazon
should be paying some taxes rather than
zero but they don't want to vote for
Bernie they don't like the dynamic that
was formed along a lot of these black
white lines and by that I don't I don't
mean racially I mean the sort of either
you're with us or against us we are
against not only the Republican
establishment but also the Democratic
the people that surround him the
self-description as a Democratic
Socialist and it can be very deceptive
to spend too much time only in the
online echo chambers we often hear hey
socialism is more popular than ever
thirty percent see it favorably 35 40
percent see it favorably that's still
not the majority this stuff matters and
there's lots of people floating around
on Twitter
blaming only the Democratic
establishment and corporate media and
all of this stuff in the same way that
black voters don't support the
Democratic Party because they're stupid
right the right loves to say black
voters aren't reven the things they're
just brainwashed by Democrats know
that's not true that's that's an ink
completely incorrect and discriminatory
thing that the right says about black
voters supporting the Democratic Party
people also aren't voting for candidates
other than Bernie because they are
stupid they just don't want to vote for
Bernie and they're actively making that
decision they like the ideas in many
cases but they don't like the total
package and if we don't recognize that
we're just going to keep losing right be
we we don't have to be in this position
every primary of being like well right
now we're losing if we can just pull out
Florida with 55% we need to repackage
the ideas and I don't know who the right
candidate is but unless we zoom out and
say not who does Twitter like or who
does read it like or how big was the
rally crowd the question has to be
inclusive of who would Democrats in
northern Florida vote for unless we do
that and answer those questions the same
outcome is going to repeat itself
continue following this story on our
Instagram page at David Pakman show
while you're there follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman if you ever
feel like you just don't have enough
time to read all the books you want to
read you have to check out one of my
favorite apps called blinka splink a--
stakes thousands of popular non-fiction
books and distills each one down into an
e-book or audio book that you can get
through in just fifteen minutes where
you're getting all the key takeaways
from the book just imagine how you'll be
able to expand your horizons and
knowledge by being able to soak up all
of the important insights from ten
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't
time for or you can use it to revisit a
book you've already read or use it to
preview a book before you buy the full
version and read it I recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great Stephen Hawking this is a book
that I have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on blink
as' blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video